if you clicked on this video then let's
just get this out of the way up front
there are major spoilers ahead for the
most recent episode of Game of Thrones
last warning before things turn into a
spoiler filled free-for-all entitled the
belts the latest Game of Thrones episode
saw Daenerys Targaryen and her Allied
forces carry out their siege of King's
Landing it all came off the back of Dany
witnessing Cersei Lannister executing
her friend me Sande and Daenerys herself
executing Varys after he betrayed her
clearly Daenerys wasn't in the comest or
most rational state of mind when she and
her troops rocked up to the Westerosi
capital watching me Sande be decapitated
quickly realizing that people in
Westeros loved Jon Snow and will support
his legitimate claim to the Iron Throne
and the understanding that she only
knows fear in the country proved too
much for Daenerys she unleashed fire and
fury on King's Landing commanding her
dragon to burn the city down even after
its people rang the bells and
surrendered but it wasn't just dragon
fire that blazed through King's Landing
bursts of emerald flames erupted
throughout the city too for those who
may not recall that's wildfire a highly
flammable and incredibly volatile liquid
created by the pyromancers of the
ancient society known as the alchemists
guild
wildfire begins as a bright green liquid
and burns with great strength when it's
ignited it doesn't carry quite the same
properties as normal fire as it cannot
be extinguished with water only with
sand season 8 episode 5 wasn't the first
time viewers caught a glimpse of
wildfire of course Cersei utilizes a
huge cache of wildfire hidden beneath
the Sept of Baelor to blow up the place
of worship during season 6 which kills
then Queen Margaery Tyrell
that allows Cersei to claim the Iron
Throne after her son King Tommen
Baratheon takes his own life following
the fiery carnage wildfire appears in
season two as well when Tyrion Lannister
learns that Cersei is planning to use
wildfire as a weapon of defense against
Stannis Baratheon in his fleet on
Blackwater Bay Tyrion and Bronn pay a
visit to the head of the alchemists
guild and Kings Landing just ahead of
the Battle of the Blackwater The
Alchemist tells Tyrion and bran that
wildfire might be potent enough to burn
off people's appendages and then
highlights an intense connection between
wildfire and House Targaryen after the
Dragons died wildfire was the key to the
Targaryen power wildfire was discussed
again during season 3 on the fifth
episode of that season Jaime Lannister
reveals the true reason he slaughtered
the Mad King Aerys the tyrant wanted to
burn every last inch of King's Landing
using wildfire the Mad King realizing
that his opponents were going to win the
battle had his Pyromancer stuck stores
of wildfire in various locations
throughout King's Landing
Jaime explains to Brienne of Tarth that
the Mad King was obsessed with the stuff
and he loved watching his enemies burn
he burns blood didn't like anyone who
was against him as past seasons have
established wildfire is a chosen weapon
of House Targaryen one that its members
favored when its greatest advantage over
the Seven Kingdoms their dragons all
died out it only makes sense that
wildfire would appear again when
Daenerys the last living child of the
Mad King let the devastation of death
the reality of fear and the overwhelming
desire for power turn her into a version
of her father the Mad King attempted to
burn King's Landing with wildfire and
couldn't but his daughter finished the
job decades later it's almost guaranteed
that the Wildfire seen on season 8
episode 5 came from the stores that the
mad Kings pyromancers placed across
King's Landing ones no one had found
until Danny ordered drogon to blast his
flames everywhere it also draws yet
another terrifying parallel between
Daenerys and her father the man she
tried so hard not to become
up to this point will she suffer the
same fate he did killed by a night with
a swift hand the final episode of Game
of Thrones will reveal the answer check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about Game
of Thrones are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the belt so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]